the beauty of the wave equation Mehta
fists itself in several ways it is
mathematically simple elegant and has
helped to unveil a new understanding of
the physical world classically a
particle can be described by saying that
at a time T it is at a point X in space
and through the equations of motion at
some later time it is moved to a new
position this description has to be
abandoned when describing particles in
quantum mechanics the wave equation
describes how waves propagate it can be
used to describe water waves sound waves
light and radio waves it began with a
simple model of a vibrating violin
string and has become something that can
study a diverse range of phenomena its
link to music has helped us understand
why we can hear sound and why some
combinations are hominis while others
are jarring it is a poster child for the
idea that mathematical principles
developed in one area on their own can
become really helpful in other areas its
beauty comes from its elegance and its
utility when we use the wave equation we
are describing the amplitude of a wave
but when we use the wave equation to
describe a single particle it can become
confusing what this amplitude actually
is with the way of description we no
longer are able to know the precise
location of a particle instead we look
at the probability of finding it at any
given point the amplitude is how likely
it is to be there this leap has both
empowered and haunted quantum mechanics
ever since and has surrendered our world
to being built on a foundation of
uncertainty